Then all of a sudden pull back.
I don't even know back.
I don't even know if it's corruption.
I,
I think it's a,
you don't know if it's good then I'll go.
In other words where I mean is that,
I just think that the system in place is the only way you,
yeah,
that's perfect.
That's what it is.
Yeah.
So I mean they're not going to fix that system of that system has made them
billions of dollars.
They're going to do whatever meager patchwork they need to do within their
lifetime to keep on the majority of the wealth that they've acquired.
I've said before,
I try it,
try getting rid of a law now try,
just try.
Let's skip.
Let's step outside of the boundaries cause I tire of these,
these questions and these,
these,
these things.
And one of the reasons why I tire of it is because everyone seems to have some
sort of a position in this machine and everyone is describing all the varieties
of issues within these positions of these,
these different statements and different belief systems that everybody has a
subscribed to when it comes to this world.
And how everything runs.
What's the ideal way to do it?
If you could,
if you were a guy,
and I know that you've thought of this,
if you were a guy that could stop everything and figure out how to make an even
system,
what would you do?
How would you engineer it?
If someone came up to you and said,
listen dude,
we're gonna let you go on television.
You have a year to formulate a plan.
I think you're a smart guy and I think this is what the world needs.
The world's needs a smart dude who thinks out of the box.
You get together,
you have one year come up with a fucking plan as to how to redistribute the
whole thing had had a refigure out where where the money gets stored and what's
the money is based on and you know,
what are,
what are acceptable interest rates.
And I would probably do,
I would probably start with a flat tax.
And what I mean by that is I would have,
no matter who you are,
where you stand,
you pay 30% you pay 30% across the board.
So instead of having 6,000 pages of taxes,
I know there are problems with it,
but for the most part,
I'd make it as fair as possible.
May Not be as fair to,
you know,
rich people pay more,
they're gonna pay more ultimately.
But you know,
poor people still have to pay 30% right now.
A lot of poor people don't pay any taxes at all.
Maybe that's good.
See,
this is where I would step back and the tax code is so fucking complicated.
Did I might just say flat tax across the board,
no matter who you are,
you pay 30% of your income.
I think if you are poor and you are struggling,
you should have to pay much less.
And I think that a guy like me should have to pay more.
I think that,
I agree with that.
I think it's,
it's a creepy argument.
And I,
I,
if I,
this is the caveat though,
if I believed that it was being spent wisely,
if I believe that that was the answer and I don't,
this brings me back to the doers.
And the question is that I don't believe there's any way.
I don't believe that any large bureaucracy,
I don't care if it's a corporation,
especially not the US government,
because there's no accountability and you don't have to have a bottom line.
You don't have to produce a profit,
you,
there's no,
there's no marketplace telling you,
you,
you go out of business.
I mean since what was it?
1960 fucking letters problem.
It's a business.
How many,
how many,
how many fortune five hundreds are have the 500 companies that were in
existence.
It started when they started tracking the fortune 500 how many are in existence
since 1967 how many earnings?
It's not the 500 I believe eight are still running.
Companies go out of business all the fucking time.
Why?
They just run out.
They just run out of product to whatever their ship.
That's how it goes.
And guess what?
These rooms for another startup.
Yes.
Where that hasn't happened,
the pharmaceutical industries there are so fucking big that they control the
FDA.
A whole nother story.
So the point is this,
my feeling,
my feeling is that the only way that you are always going to have private look
at,
look at the military industrial complex.
You are always going to have private sector people manipulating tax dollars and
government agencies to their,
to their benefit then and as a result,
it's impossible for the government not to get involved in the marketplace.
It's impossible.
You don't have a free market,
you don't have a market system anymore,
especially not in the banking industry has been regulated since fucking 1900
[inaudible].
So what I would do very simply is I'd have a flat tax and I would ultimately get
rid of all subsidies,
all except for Medicare,
Medicaid,
and that I would hope and including social security,
I would overhaul in that I would find out who deserves fucking Medicare.
There are a lot of very wealthy people who get it to shows all the sudden become
a really boring political debate.
The issues,
I'm sorry,
but it goes on forever.
It does real specific where your points,
and I was starting to fade.
You should talk about the corruption in Avon and corporations.
Avon because pink cars,
every time you talk about question,
I think both to bring it down to a general thing.
People understand.
I think you know,
you just got to realize that.
Just always ask yourself,
how the fuck would I react in that situation?
If you really learned about this stuff,
a lot of this shit is you get into these like these guys get in and stuff and
you're like,
that guy's fucking evil.
And in movies you see the evil guy with the black hat,
Shit's always way more complicated and way more fucking gray than that because
corporate,
you know me,
you've seen the documentary of the corporation,
right?
Where they detail how corporations act as sociopath's,
the act of psychopaths.
They ask these people who don't care about the repercussions because there's a
diffusion of responsibility because there's a million people in the corporation.
There you go.
Deep Shit guys.
Well,
I think,
you know,
when I look at what's going on right now,
I see a bunch of different factors and the big factor that I think is a not
being paid as much attention to in all of this is that the whole problem is the
access to information and that this system has always been corrupt and the
system has always been running fairly,
but we didn't know it.
We didn't know what the way we know it now.
And the access to information is unprecedented now.
And because of the people were starting to exchange information and because of
this access to information and social networking,
they're allowed to do it in real time and they're organized.
It's also easy to manipulate information,
you know,
that's the irony of it is like you got you,
you have so much access to information,
it's really easy to manipulate.
You see political parties do that shit all the time.
Sure.
Of course.
Yeah.
Eventually it's going to,
there's going to be something that allows people to know whether something not,
it's true.
And that's when things are going to get really strange.
And it's really not that big of a deal to be able to exclude disinformation and
incorrect information to have some way of proving things to be factually correct
before,
uh,
they released and spread their will.
That's not that far outside of the realm of possibility.
So right now there's a,
you mean it's whether or not you can prove something to be true and factual,
you know,
that,
like when you look at like these databases like Wolfram Alpha and you know,
like Siri,
the Siri thing,
we talking to the apple thing and it goes to the web and find out information
and brings it back to you.
There's going to eventually be a very clear system of finding out what is true
and what is not true.
There's going to be a,
it's going to be very easy to detect what is propaganda,
what is actual fact,
and you're gonna be able to know it in real time.
And when that happens,
then it's going to be way harder to pull off corruption.
Well,
that's what I,
I just keep wondering,
like I always find myself asking how are things going to get better in 20 years?
Worst,
how about 40?
It's better.
Listen man,
here's what everybody's woe is being about.
Man.
You know,
there was a study recently that I tweeted the talked about violence that it was
a um,
uh,
Kurt's well study violence is at an all time low in per capita.
Like people are much,
much less violent and much it's life today as much safer than it's ever been at
any other time in human history.
Things are getting better.
It's just right now I think we're in the process of a birth,
we're in the process of a,
another stage and it's really close to bottlenecking.
There's with the,
the,
the influx of technology and information into the world of the monkey is,
is so complete right now and we are biologically struggling to keep up with all
this new shit that's going on around us all the time and all this new
information and all these new challenges and all this,
you know,
these,
the,
these new issues that are presenting themselves to us.
And it's thing because of technology,
it almost feels like,
you know,
they're talking about the planet and it's warming and all that stuff.
And I,
I always feel like is that,
is that essentially like,
um,
the,
the idea that we keep growing as like literally an organism where we're going to
have to mesh with machines just to survive in an environment.
It's all kind of part of it,
you know?
Well,
there's also the idea that machines are a life form in and of itself.
You look like,
I,
I've always said this,
if you look at like,
I'm stupid,
I could keep old computers.
I have like an old,
a gray,
one of those,
uh,
Tan Apple fucking towers.
It's in my garage somewhere.
It doesn't work anymore.
I have an old laptop with a little track wheel on it and it doesn't work anymore
either.
Those are skeletons.
Those are dead animals.
Those are things that they,
their,
their predecessors,
you know,
or rather there were,
there they are,
the predecessors from today's sleek laptops,
you know,
there,
they're old shitty,
the,
they're clunky.
They make weird noises when he turned them on.
You know,
I mean they are essentially the monkeys of the,
you know,
in comparison to us and I think it's real possible.
But if we do have some sort of an artificial intelligence and we do create a
life form out of computers,
is able to recreate other life forms,
I think that's probably the next stage.
Why are we so we,
when we personally think that it's so important that we continue this,
this animal struggle with emotions and sperm and eggs and biology as we know it,
when biology is we're knowing might be biology,
we might be much more comfortable inside of a robot.
But I was going to say,
I mean,
but,
but human beings,
it seems are on the verge of actually creating a whole,
a whole new kind of bio synthetic biology that we're going to be able to match.
But who's to say that that's synthetic biology?
You can't be just as way better or a better way better man.
This is like a,
W we,
we have is like an old car that's made out of cardboard.
That's it.
And we're on our way to building some fucking carbon fiber fiber optic laced
electronic fucking mid engine beast,
constructing ears that can hear a mile away,
et cetera.
I'll take it.
The problem is it keeps raining and our fucking cardboard house slowly falling
apart.
But like Jesus Christ,
hurry up,
fix this cardboard car,
the cardboard cars all fucked up and the new cars not ready yet.
It's a matter of whether or not we can complete our cycle of,
of,
of technology and artificial intelligence.
And then combined with it before we blow ourselves up,
you have very,
very smart people.
Um,
uh,
reengineering,
reverse engineering the brain,
the eardrum,
the eye,
the red blood cell.
We just reverse engineered the red blood cell of a dog.
And that means that if you reverse engineer it and you know exactly how it
works,
you can make a replica of it with synthetic material.
Uh,
and which would be a Nano Bot because it can,
it's about that big.
So,
so pan on nanotechnology and then re replicating what you just reverse
engineered.
If you can do that,
then it is.
It is clear and it follows up.
By the way,
we're also doing with an I or doing it with an eardrum,
et cetera.
If you can do that well,
when is the brain when they're already working on trying to reverse engineer the
brain?
It really fucking is really cool questions.
It really does,
man,
because if you can do that and you can create a machine,
it's the blade runner question.
When does it become a person you know when fucking,
what's her name and blade runner?
The Really Daryl Hannah.
When she cried when she was sad.
Did you feel sad for her?
She's beautiful.
She's a robot robot robot.
The want some deck.
That's right.
You can kill you.
Ooh.
I'd like if you fuck a robot that's really lifelike.
Is that cheating?
Yes.
It's going to happen.
What's going to happen?
Because the robot's going to go to your house and kill your wife because your
wife wants to unplug it.
Yeah.
Robots have emotions,
bro.
They build them in.
If they build an emotion,
if they're going to build in,
something's going to be kind to you.
The only way kindness counts is if you earn it kindness.
If you're just an emperor and you walk in and everybody just sucks your Dick
after awhile,
the chicken is boring.
You know the Yin and the Yang of things is there for a reason.
You have to have struggled in order to appreciate the good times.
You cannot,
I don't appreciate relaxing unless I put in hard work.
I really don't.
That's the biggest question was a lot of computer scientists who are saying when
these robots will,
which means they,
when you say that,
and when they develop consciousness,
meaning they are conscious of their own existence,
the nature of anything that is conscious of its own existence or even just
having its own existence,
whether it's a cancer cell and aunt or a human being,
is that you want to replicate and stay alive forever and,
and you know,
but those are biological instincts because they're,
they're programmed into the world that we operate.
We are creating,
computers are going to be essentially the exact,
the mimic.
We are mimicking ourselves,
not necessarily true because there's no benefit to staying alive.
What?
What benefit does the computer have to maintain in consciousness?
If there's no,
if there's no cells or genetics or hormones pumped into your system telling you
stick it in there and shoot off loads because you want to breed.
True.
What is,
where's the incentive?
What happens does not the computer,
if it's infinitely wise,
doesn't embrace the notion that it does not have to be a complete because what
it is is a part of everything in the first place and there's the idea of life is
not really necessary.
It's just we hold onto it because biologically it's how we spread our work.
We spread our work and you're never going to die anyway.
It doesn't matter.
Anyways.
The computer should be smart enough to know,
go ahead.
Shut me off bitch.
That's I'm here forever.
Well,
they had seen that.
What about when they start making computers that are smarter than them and all
that?
Well,
they become infinitely smart almost immediately.
I think that people always say,
well,
if they're going to have respect for our biological heritage and what they don't
realize that we're going to be changing too.
That's what we're going to be changing case.
I think when you start talking about computers being this advanced,
you're talking about human beings because I'm going to tell you right now,
as soon as they got a bio,
chem,
bio compatible machine that I can download information into et Cetera,
you're going to,
you're going to have it in your body attached already to my fucking phone.
My,
my phone is a part of me.
When I leave my house and I don't have my iPhone,
I feel like I'm missing a part of my body.
And you know,
if you read Tim Ferriss's book,
did you read the part about having a cell phone in your pocket?
How it cooks your fucking ball?
Well,
one of the things that he did was he did a test on his sperm count and he did a
test and found out that a sperm count was fairly low and he's a really good
shape and he's young and he was like,
what the fuck is going on?
So then he starts doing all this reading on different studies and one of the
things he comes to his studies about cell phone usage and keeping your cell
phone in your front pocket and how it affects your sperm count.
The radiation from your fucking cell phone diminishes your sperm count.
Yeah.
He doesn't even carry it on him anymore.
He like,
he shuts it off and he puts on his pocket and
speak.
I've always done anyway,
but I have it in my pocket all the time and he said that he took,
took the time off,
stopped having the phone in his pocket.
It started eating Brazil nuts.
Apparently they have zinc in them and it's a very healthy for bringing back your
sperm count in a misnomer for everybody listening.
Brazil nuts can also be very,
very allergic.
My mother will die.
My mother will die if she eats one.
If I,
if I want one,
my whole throat closes.
I'm going to eat some right in front of you.
Brazil nuts.
Just make sure you're not,
you're not allergic.
Uh,
good,
good call.
Um,
so either way I take zinc supplements or do whatever the fuck is Ferris did.
And by taking the phone out of his pocket,
he,
you know,
radically increase the sperm count.
That's scary.
It's a really good book.
What was that?
Oh,
that was in with that in the second chapter.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what chapters did.
I read it on the toilet.
So I pick it up and I'll read it.
For instance,
I've been eating so well,
my toilet trips have been shorter and shorter.
I used to,
you know,
when I was just eating straight,
meet Brock Lesnar status.
Oh,
take these giant dinosaurs shits that would take 20 minutes and I would look
just like orange fears,
jug out my legs would go numb,
my feet would go numb.
I'd have a hard time standing up,
but I've been,
uh,
drinking this a Kale shake.
I make every morning now.
Shit.
Yeah.
I cut it in this crazy Vitamix blender.
I throw in cucumbers and Kale and man,
I feel so good.
You have so much energy.
It's really,
it's,
it's amazing.
Cashews,
Goji Berries,
some almonds,
strawberries,
blueberries and uh,
some hemp seed and a,
and protein powder and almond milk.
And you feel fucking,
I mean,
I do it.
I do that Dr. Schultz Superfood,
which is this awesome kelp green thing I'm telling you,
man.
I have energy for days.
It's just incredible.
Yeah,
man.
Diet is so God damn report.
And it's one of the things that,
and by the way,
I know food tastes fucking delicious.
You know,
I'm,
I'm the first guy after a comedy show,
especially,
we'll go to canter's and I'll have a giant fucking Pastrami Reuben with French
fries.
And you're getting the nutrition you need.
Most people are walking around and malnourished.
I,
yes.
And then the shit food treats.
You got it.
And you're not,
not just vitamins either.
I used to try to just do it with vitamins.
And I think multivitamins are important.
I think it's important to recommend to,
I don't know if like,
you know,
I think certain people with certain demands have higher demands.
Like especially if you're an athlete,
if you're doing a lot of Jujitsu,
like when people say,
you know what you need for a,
your,
your recommended daily requirement of vitamins and protein,
all that stuff.
I always look at them and I go,
okay,
but what are you doing physical?
Are you doing what I'm doing man,
because I'm fighting for my life?
You know,
and I don't think people understand that.
I did a thing,
I mean,
men's fitness this month,
there's a thing on my workout,
you know,
the,
uh,
they did this whole,
thing on my kettlebell workout and now Steve Mack Walls Maxwell's in town and
we'll working out this weekend together too.
I'm super excited about that.
This week I'm going to do some hardcore kettlebell drills.
People don't fucking realize how hard some people work out and I don't work out
nearly as hard as the guy like Cain Velasquez does,
or a guy like George Saint Pierre does.
I just simply don't put in the amount of sessions in a week that they do.
But when I do do it,
I go fucking all out and you can't do that and just eat spaghetti.
Now you can't do that and not have vitamins and not have protein.
And um,
I have one of the things that I've done over the course of being involved in
combat sports since I was literally a child,
you know,
um,
I haven't had a moment since I was 14 years old that I wasn't learning or
practicing some type of martial art.
It became an obsession super early in my life and that there's a direct
correlation to me with good performance,
good movement,
healthy body,
mind,
spirit,
and Diet by when I've eaten sheriff tillers talking about,
I said,
food is a drug and how you,
the way you combine it,
the kind of food you take in,
it will react within your body exactly the way a drug,
well,
either it will have a positive hormonal effect,
a negative hormonal.
The problem is good food.
Like there's a lot of shit foods,
food,
it's got no or very little nutrients,
but God damn it tastes good.
You know,
I have a pineapple and anchovy pizza.
It's one of my big fucking problems.
I've got a problem.
I like double and pineapple,
double anchovies.
Sure.
That's filled with arsenic and all kinds of creepy fucking shit and that ocean,
that ocean is just filled with heavy metal poisoning and a,
anyway,
it's a fucking,
I got a real problem,
but after I eat it,
I feel like shit.
I always feel like I got harpooned like I got shot with some animal
tranquilizer.
I think that the way that to start eating better is first of all to to educate
yourself and start eating better,
but then just start noticing the difference.
Because what happens is you start getting a pleasurable response when you eat
well and what's good for your body and a negative response when you go out and
eat a whole pizza at pizza or whatever you,
you,
you won't feel as good as if you have a shake.
I was just talking about it.
Well,
my point was this was,
this is my point.
My point is in all my years I've done it both ways.
I've done it where I eat shit food and I've done it where I really good food and
when I do,
when I really good food,
I have a different body.
It's that simple.
It works way better.
It just works way better.
Nobody before they get into the UFC eats fucking three Carls jr break bacon
cheeseburgers and fries and a large coke.
You just don't do that because if you do,
your body's going to perform like shit.
You know why?
Because your body is fighting off poison.
Your body is in a war to process all this shit.
Saturated fats and trans fats and those fats with Dick's,
right Brian?
Yes.
He said,
what's that?
I said,
I was just kidding about the making out with the transvestite.
And my friends thought,
man,
you know,
somebody needs to,
somebody needs to create a guide for life and have all these different ideas in
there.
And one of them has got to be the importance of diet and exercise.
And even though I know a lot of smart fucking people,
I know so many intelligent people who are really super creative and really
interesting and they don't take care of their fucking shell.
They don't take care of their body man.
They don't,
they don't understand.
And they'll look at you like your a frivolous or like you're,
you know,
you're,
there's a lot of negative connotation.
It's like when I call you a health nut,
oh,
you're a health nut or you're an exercise freak.
Well,
no,
you're narcissistic because the inclination,
the implication.
Now I just know that I feel way better and way more productive when I,
when I'm,
when I'm like this,
then I will,
I'm not going to have a belly when I'm fucking,
you know,
45 50 55 they say a certain percentage of people who have chimpanzee DNA.
I have chimpanzee Danae I mean not just chimpanzee DNA,
rather neanderthal DNA.
There's no question about it.
I got some of the on a tall in my past,
there's no doubt about it.
I this was like a certain percentage of humans and large number.
Yeah.
We somehow or another assimilated with the neanderthals.
They didn't use to think that they take that now muscular like stronger.
I don't know.
No,
I think you know that that has to do with what part of environment,
you know,
your,
your DNA comes from,
you know,
whether you or your family were Sicilian peasants that are carrying rocks all
day.
Exactly.
And,
and endomorphs seem to be a function of society and in Diet and also the,
one of the things they're finding out is a stress from inside the womb.
If they're the,
the,
the mother during pregnancy is malnourished in any way.
The kid has an inclination to hold on to carbs and fats and they're like,
oh yeah,
there's a,
there was another part of that zeitgeists thing that was really interesting.
It was a whole,
a lot of that that,
uh,
the Zike is the part that I watch the only watch the first 15 minutes or so.
And,
uh,
what was really interesting about it was all the different things they were
talking about,
about health and cancer and,
and illnesses and about,
uh,
people who develop breast cancer.
There's like a gene,
the,
a lot of people get breast cancer and they can find that gene and say,
you are susceptible to breast cancer.
People who have breast cancer,
only three out of 10 have that gene.
Seven out of 10 don't have that gene.
You know,
and they're,
they're trying to figure out,
well,
what is it that causes people to get cancer?
What is,
it causes people to be,
uh,
to,
to have a violent behavior?
Well,
we'll,
what are their genes for violent behavior?
Yes,
there are,
but you know,
they're realizing people who've been abused at childhood have a different
genetic structure.
Then people haven't been in their body,
their body reboots or jacks,
your body triggers to structure can change your body changes to deal with this
horrible environment and this horrible hand we live in dealt with evolution,
immediate evolution.
It's like this,
the system is is all set up to respond to whatever is coming in made sense
though.
You know it's like I was talking to John Brenkus who does that show sports
science and they were talking about feel Max and they were,
they tried to tire can't Velazco guys out and they hadn't been running,
they couldn't get his heart rate over 165 a based no matter what they do,
you're fucking with that guy.
And some of it is that there's definitely like some people have like a certain
genetic structure where they can utilize oxygen better,
but a lot of it's,
it's,
it's also repetition and practice and body kids incredibly adapt.
Yeah.
He wouldn't have that kind of cardio if you didn't train.
I mean he's got definitely,
he's got some freak genetics,
but guess what a lot of Mexicans do.
A lot of Mexicans have amazing endurance.
You know Julio Cesar Chavez was known for barely training and he had amazing
endurance like at some of his fights.
He like he would just come in and just beat the fuck out of guys,
break them down the pace and you never done,
Gosh,
you just rake your body.
Right.
I just saw a documentary on Gilbert Melendez is the strike force lightweight
champion.
He's a Mexican dude.
Amazing endurance.
His kid is,
he's known for just putting it on people and he has even said that he thinks
that part of his endurance is genetic.
Obviously works as hard as any professional athlete on the planet,
but as long distance runners come from Peru and so that's a different,
that's activity in Peru I'm saying.
Yeah,
but different activity,
long distance running is all,
it's all,
it's a different,
it's a different kind of cardio that you haven't fighting where you have
anaerobic and aerobic all mixed in together.
That's like real combat,
like sort of cardio.
It's a different kind of cardio.
I asked me why I liked,
um,
why I love MMA so much that it's the Ross.
Was this a girl or a guy that was asking this question?
If you did,
you grab her by the nape of the hair in the back of her neck and you just,
just gently wrap your cock or on their lips slop.
Hey guys,
I got to get a spanking.
Okay.
And then put it back in your pants.
Don't even have a socket.
Just put a bug in your parents just,
just to,
just for the fuck out of her dirty bitch.
Why do I like what?
But it's,
it's just so I got,
I just got a little bit of a bonus just now,
but it's,
it's literally like,
it's the Ross form of competition.
Of course guys fight,
you know,
um,
the movie warrior did not get its fair shake.
You were in warrior and you had a great roles.
It was,
it was a fun role,
but that movie did not get its fair shake.
That was a great movie.
It wasn't even factual.
It was silly.
They fought for two days in a row and it was a little crazy tournament,
but that didn't matter.
The just the story itself and maybe they could have worked around that where
they didn't have a two day tournament or whatever,
but it didn't matter though the story and the movie worked.
It was a good movie.
It was.
It was decent.
It was great and a very few.
What the fuck moments I like to do shows nobody watches like death valley by the
way.
That's not tonight.
Tonight.
Monday at 11 nobody's watching it.
No,
but it's a great show man.
Really funny to watch it tonight.
I told you I'll do it.
I want to play a werewolf man.
You're going to,
if we get picked up,
I already talked to them.
They loved the idea that like Joe Rogan play Werewolf.
It'd be awesome.
I'd love to play.
How good are the special effects?
I don't want to play a tape.
I watched ginger snaps last night.
Somebody told me to rent ginger snaps like dude's good mood werewolf movie.
It's kind of funny for a long time.
It's pretty fun.
It's about two girls that are going through high school and they're,
they're loners,
they're kind of outsiders and they're sisters and they're kind of golf and one
of them gets bit by a werewolf.
It's pretty fucking funny.
There's a lot of good stuff to it up until you see the Werewolf and it's like
Jesus Christ.
Did you have any budget?
I mean it's just,
it looks like they take a balloon and drew a Werewolf scary face on the blue and
stuck it in your face.
Like that's the wolf man.
So bad.
A great special effects man.
I'm proud of the show.
I really am.
I think it's really funny.
And it's on MTV.
What time?
11 o'clock on Monday tonight.
Watch it tonight.
Schedule it on my phone right now and I think tomorrow we got Josh McDermitt.
Josh supposed to be doing it because we started doing this thing from the Ice
House live at the Ice House and it's on,
it's broken up into two parts.
One part is on my iTunes,
on the Joe Rogan experience.
And the other part is on desk squad and a desk squad is the one that Brian runs.
And what it essentially is,
is,
um,
it's all of our friends that have podcasts like Thompson Guerra.
We're talking,
Brian counted doing one.
He's going to do one now too.
Yes,
I am Sam triple.
He does it all these different people do it.
And we decided to,
uh,
that would be a good way to also promote death squads.
We have it set up.
I'm going to do it on that red bands.
Uh,
that's fine yet.
And we start Brendan Walsh,
uh,
this week too.
I think what I'm gonna start my podcast just going to be,
I'm going to say,
I'm going to have,
I guess I'm just gonna ask them like 10 really good questions.
I've always wanted to do that,
man.
You're a conversationalist.
Just anything that's interesting to you.
Just sit down and talk about it though there.
Yeah,
but you,
you should have a podcast.
There's no doubt about it.
You're a fascinating dude and you know,
and it's going to be fun in it.
It helps you evolve ideas and people call you on your bullshit and it helps you.
It also helps you realize like how many times you repeat the same things over
and over again.
How many,
how many subjects you obsess on it and it becomes a normal part of your everyday
life.
But when you start trying to pump that on a podcast,
people like,
look bitch,
I heard that already.
Stop fucking freaking out about the same thing every God damn week.
You know,
you gotta you gotta evolve.
Yeah.
Well we talked about occupy Wall Street like three times in a row now,
but I think we're,
we're also doing it with different people just sort of get their different
reactions because I think this is a pretty important part of human history right
now.
I think it's funny that you both said that you really like Daniel Day.
What's his name is Daniel Day Lewis.
Yeah,
cause it's that comes up with all your friends and industry guys.
I'll sitting out here.
We're going out and talking about,
yeah,
I guess it comes down to it.
Every time I do knuckles up,
by the way,
I can't get you out of my head so it kind of sucks.
Materialize.
Feels like it comes down to like people.
What inspires you is not even so much the person but the effort.
You know like when you see that kind of like holy fuck you go beyond yourself
there.
I don't really like soccer,
but if I see a bad ass soccer player and the show me a clip online,
I'll watch him.
I'll watch him do his thing.
Did you see that guy by the way in South Africa riding his mountain bike,
his doors and he got hit by that?
I answer low.
Yeah.
You get hit by a buck with the horns and then he landed on his head and it was
making those,
I've been knocked out noises like,
oh this is that you make when you get severely concussed,
that's when you know that's when you know.
Also you feel that weight and power of a 440 pounds and running full clip
hitting you with it's fucking horns.
No fuck are they just kept running.
He just,
Oh,
whoops.
I hit a guy and a bike.
No big deal.
Accident or was he trying,
no,
it was an accident.
He was running.
He happened to be sprinting and as they're coming down and he just timed it shit
and slammed into him.
Yeah.
Fuck Africa,
dude.
Africa can suck my dick insects the size of your fucking forearms.
How about the parasites?
Forget about the insects that you can see.
How about,
oh,
whoops.
I washed my toe and I actually had a hangnail and some shit got inside of it and
it camped out in my body and grew and made a chain all the way to my brain and
it started sucking brain juice out of my big toe and I went to the doctor's
like,
why is my big toe leaking?
Oh,
that's cerebral spinal fluid.
How?
What the fuck's going on?
Or there's a pipeline between your fucking brain and your toe created by some
parasite.
No,
maybe I just made it up.
But maybe it could be true.
There's plenty of shit inside Africa that can Africa twice.
Fuck you up.
I remember I was saying I was a kid,
I was an African.
It was,
it was dark out and there were the,
we were staying at his place where there were the grounds,
there were these,
you could walk around and I was going to walk around and my father goes,
you know,
walking around there or why this,
cause this is Africa.
You see a fence around here.
There are lion just over there.
You idiot
rice.
You don't have a dog in your backyard.
In Africa for example,
we've been banging around the idea of a cell phones.
How when you buy a cell phone,
you know,
you don't realize how much fucking slave labor is involved and how much we were.
Is there a Karma free cell phone?
Is there a cell phone you can buy where you don't have to worry about the Labor
being slave labor?
You don't have to worry about the minerals mind under,
you know,
treacherous conditions where people know it's impossible.
It's impossible.
Sorry.
Those minerals,
they're all from the fucking Congo man and the con that was watching vice guide
to the Congo.
Have you seen that yet?
They started releasing vice guy to the Congo.
Oh Jesus Christ is out of fucking crazy part of the world.
That is,
you actually watch it.
A hell on earth or some of those villages chose more than Mad Max Joseph Kahn,
Joseph Kony,
who runs the Lord's Resistance Army,
about 200 300 like vicious killers who do all kinds of horrible things and they
just go to,
they just mask or villages.
He's a delusional guy with military grade weapons.
It's been out there for God since the Hutu Rwanda massacre and this motherfucker
is as bad as it gets and they do the worst shit in recorded history.
It's going on right now in 2011 people don't realize that millions of people
have died.
Millions,
millions.
That sounds like an exaggeration,
but it's more that civil war has seen that Sierra Leone,
Liberia to us to a small extent,
but,
and,
and Rwanda has seen some of the most concentrated and ferocious killing in the
history of the fucking world.
Whoever you guys are the do that vice guide to travel.
All you guys are bad motherfuckers and I would love to have you guys on the
podcast if someone knows anybody that knows those guys.
Somebody does.
If somebody knows one of the guys on the,
on our message board,
but fucking Holler at me on Twitter.
Those,
those guys,
uh,
they've done some wild fucking trips.
Man.
The Liberia one is a great one.
The Thailand one,
they went to Thailand and picked up lady boys.
Woo.
Wow.
They went deep.
I saw the lady boys,
their hangover too,
right?
Derek?
Zach,
and I know I that I was with Zach Alf,
an accident.
Brody Stevens,
and we were watching the lady boys and some of them are as good looking as the
girl I was making out with from my earlier story,
better,
softer,
less.
And I said to Brody,
I go,
dude,
if you have any guts at all,
you will,
you will take that girl home and bang her.
I know it's a guy,
but you don't have the stones.
Of course he didn't do it,
but she was like go or just go,
wow.
Wow.
Scary world out there.
Just like Thailand.
Did you think you could leave?
Leave the country and me and you and a couple of other dudes,
this is the thing,
we hit 60 after the kids are grown,
kids leave the house.
We were trying to fucking the,
and we just get to a certain point where like,
listen baby,
I love you.
You love me.
I'm just gonna live in Thailand for four months out of the year.
That's how I got myself a young girl's tough.
Four months of the year,
eight months of the year,
I'll stay with China on an 18 year old a lot to me and telling me I still have
it.
Do whatever you need to do with your trainer.
I know,
you know,
I don't want to control you in any way,
just make it happen.
And he just give up.
When you go to fucking Thailand and live like a king,
then you see this,
this German tourist with warts and barnacles on his back and hot little tigers,
durable like 18 year old pretending she's into him.
It's enough to make you throw up and give you a boner at the same time.
Ladies and gentlemen,
by the way,
I'll be covered at all.
We've covered it a little bit.
Winnepeg.
Let me segue.
I'll be at a,
I think it's rumors.
I think it's called rumors at Winnipeg and I'll be this weekend and Winnipeg is
an awesome name.
I started,
have you done Calgary?
I'm doing Calgary did Calgary and we oversold the show,
so I had a hundred people on stage with me.
It was fun.
I had people on either side of me while I was on stage and cheers.
No,
no,
no.
I did a theater of it all.
I'm doing Yuck,
Yuck,
yuck.
Sit in Calgary and Winnipeg this weekend.
I've only done Yuk yuks in Vancouver,
but it's not Yuk yuks anymore.
It's another name now,
but it's still dope ass.
A little club in Vancouver,
Canada.
I love the people.
I love 20% less douchebags in America.
Great people fighting people nice as fuck.
I wished it didn't get so cold up there and they get the funny,
they get it.
They're smart.
I want to move the federal educated,
move the fuck out about that.
Generally better educated than Americans.
Better specialist in like Toronto and Vancouver and Montreal.
Yeah,
so it was Montreal though.
They're amazing.
I love Montreal.
That's the end of the show.
The fuck.
I don't know any other way to end it.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
The fleshlight,
if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight answering
the code name,
Rogan,
you get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
And then if you go to [inaudible] dot Com oh and and it and entering the
codename rogue and you can get 10% off Alpha brain and Alpha brain is the
cognitive enhancing substance that we stuffed into Brian counts face before this
podcast that made him so interesting.
Thank you sir.
Along with marijuana.
I do my best.
Sorry about my sex stories.
They were great to fucking talking about.
Why are you apologizing?
Don't apologize for being yourself,
dude.
Whimsical and I love the fun.
You are.
You are awesome.
That's awesome.
You should never change a God damn thing about you.
You are what you are.
Next time he comes on,
we will,
we will fucking fly in Jimmy Burke.
It's going to happen.
You need to meet this guy.
He's a hell of a character.
Uh,
Kelly Carlin,
we're going to get to you.
I guarantee you I'll,
I'll,
I'll call you soon.
And uh,
we also,
Josh Mcdermott's coming on.
Uh,
David tell moved.
He's going to be doing it next week.
So next week,
Tuesday or something like that.
He's on soon to lots more good shit coming up to see UFC weekend.
This is only the first of these podcasts we'd done this week.
We're going to do another one probably tomorrow.
I don't know who though.
Josh,
Josh.
And then we've got to probably do another one on Thursday,
but I'm fucking crazy.
I don't even know who it would be with.
I'm wild folks.
I'm living by the seat of my pants.
We appreciate everything that you people do.
We appreciate,
appreciate all the positive energy.
We appreciate all you people listening on your fucking treadmills and your cars
and your gyms in your life,
in your home while you're cooking.
Whatever the fuck you're doing.
We're with you bitches.
It's a movement or all together in this jihad.
Did you watch the Walmart Kadafi videos and beating him up and putting a stick
in his ass?
Yeah,
they stuffed sticks in his ass.
I recommend it.
They show him beating the shit out of him.
He wasn't bloody.
And then he became bloody and they killed him.
They beat the fuck out of him and killed him and they don't show the video of
them killing them,
unfortunately.
Pussies you showed everything else.
Pray to them around on top of a car with she on them.
It's the fucking shows ending right now.
And I'm going into another subject.
Thank you to everybody.
Uh,
and we will see you tomorrow.
Anything else,
Brian?
Oh,
subscribe to the desk squad series of podcasts.
A homie made it into the top fucking 10 this week for the first time ever.
I will be on that podcast because of a gimmick.
We,
but we,
we got ya.
Anyway.
You're right.
You fucks.
All right.
We love you guys.
We'll see you soon.
Thank you very much.
Okay.